introduce Alexander and so what did work
now forget where you work yes
Alexander's at Facebook and taught at
Friday to last year and will give us
something about information surprise
this morning so let's problem Alexander
thank you so I'd prefer to to talk about
simple things that actually make
difference and people often forget it
everybody's right now runs and matters
how many control parameters their
systems have and their machine learning
pipelines but actually all we should
remember is our bachelor degrees to do
most of the stuff so i'll be talking
about surprise which is turn out simple
and what is this reprise it actually
something that really puts you off let's
say so and it will just to go into
definition of surprise and well here I
borrowing one from Oxford Dictionary
it's a piece of news expect unexpected
it happened so suddenly let actually
some things that you didn't appreciate
well at the moment what happened and we
will be capturing these events in order
to describe tweets in this demo but in
general I want to first of all introduce
all those things through toy cartoons
and actually some theory so when Kat
explores and they it just goes around
your garden policies part of your
flowers but it's nothing that super high
school cat he sees it every day and well
suddenly something very odd happens and
that actually really puts him off and
this is like this is a moment of
surprise and clearly we can see the
surprise measured in volts and this is
actually even cited scientific papers
we've seen that everywhere so how to
quantify it it's a proxy matter for this
will be complexity that can measure any
content type which wouldn't be tied to
anything
specific very important note here is
that complex well complex things aren't
random this is a slide out of one of the
papers which actually using similar
information theory techniques to analyze
music and they were showing that good
music it just right it's not true
monastic which is liquidating beat and
it's not completely random and it's very
hard to find the sweet spot and say
we're looking into this but people do
you just look quite broader all measures
of complexity will read like a whole
family of them it's very subjective it's
like a cat the cat things or it's just
some numbers number of elements
dimensions in your system control
parameters that we love to calculate
minimal description it will torque I've
something information countries will be
after here minimal generator if you
heard about kolmogorov complexity if you
can write the shortest program to
generate the sequence or minimum energy
principle surprise quantum academia is
actually well I'll like to split them in
two parts one of them is like cognitive
sciences and they study how do we
perceive information and it's very
interesting for us because at the end of
the day we'd want to find something
naturally interesting for people
interesting for human beings when you
analyze massive datasets and there is
machine learning and they are more
interested in the half-life things how
to measure things and how to measure
differences because that's how we go
things and nice things that actually
they are play with each other so we will
take a look for example in review paper
on cognitive science they put lots of
models which are very analytical and
they ever built on very simple and
similar to information theory some of
them concepts including for example in
middle just about free energy there is a
religion brain he poses quite popular
one in machine learning where we have
this application they said transform
something for human being or also in
optimization this is example back from I
believe beginning of two thousands or
even 90s when people of micros
we're building the first routing system
and they wanted a certain section to
tell the driver only unexpected events
for example you every day have a traffic
on your road but today it's a completely
bad you won't be able to pass it through
so the system had to build model
detected and only report your price of
information without spamming you so also
just things are told you they're
combined and there are studies showing
that the way how we on images in the
videos define interesting bit of
information and what we can learn to
these approaches not exactly entropy but
surprise approaches are very similar and
we will define the same bits of
information in video streaming for
example corporate spell very simple
simple should we have pictures that is
doesn't change and between our prior
post here is very little difference
nothing happens should we just swap for
random noise it's a big event and
clearly you would be caught by
surprising you'll be watching video but
in some time you'll be turning channel
off it's not that interesting for you
anymore in am a little bit different
heads up all about optimizations about
decision trees max entropy principle all
we know about this is called like
basically anomaly detection or one class
classification or novelty measures there
are quite a few different approaches
probabilistic distance domain-specific
the main based reconstruction based
information theoretic but well I bet all
of us would came across with all this
problems especially when we were logging
something worth trying to detect where
something broke and to report you but
let's go to the cat so the cat has his
date his garden he has tiny attention
span only one pot and he has his own
like brain trying to Moodle was actually
to expect from the world and this bill
built his surprise whether he's seen
like the plant he he was okay with which
were there
yesterday before ignores it or find
something interesting while doing so
here this is data model it's similar to
anomaly detection pipelines so focus on
surprising their information theory and
to quantify surprise elites back to your
bachelor's degree it's some measures is
about zero but if we exactly know that
event had happened it's equal to one and
it's in range of probabilities events of
different states like pots or astronauts
are independent and we're deriving what
do we know self information and when we
know is it flip a fair coin gives you
exactly one bit of information and bit
it's exactly this part it's log base 2
and should be seeing something very
expected our self information goes to 0
should we see something completely
unexpected it will go to the finiti
because while seeing an astronaut in the
garden it has applications and one of
the applications for example in selected
information source sure you might be
after very random information source but
should you be behaving in a society
which sensible that allows you to
organize better ways to propagate
information in network societies it's
actually part of my studies have been
doing in fellow Sampson a while ago it's
not only concerned about this it's about
more emergent behavior which patterns
emerging large-scale web agents or
people behave so but it's clearly
information surprise was so to be I've
been showing that it's one of the
driving factors to have beneficial
society organization so if we'll go back
to model for cat and think about his
knowledge what he knows about the world
he knows about ports and astronauts and
quantify his knowledge it's what we know
self information expected well yourself
information as entropy a Shannon entropy
it's basically all about all terms we
summon them together and maximum value
will be all events or equal and minimum
value will be a ventra p only one event
is known so basically nothing surprise
well it's always the same itz pots or I
don't know what I'll see and that's that
is surprise for the maxim was least the
formative list informative and yeah it's
basically a uniform distribution and as
busy statistical mechanic has clear
length informations hearing on this
terms where we can apply this it's a one
of the nice examples which is actually
very visual and people love it it's
analyzing binaries when you give an
unknown binary and you want really to
dive into you can visualize who is
entropy you can slice your binary into
tiny windows whether entropy which
window and that's not lessee for example
this database on is light part when it's
more lower values it's basically English
taxed having old labels for the cities
and the first parts which are very
fluctuation there are mattresses of
different numbers insured as a regular
large if you mattress whether it's high
or low entropy value the nice website on
internet called bean beef allows you to
visualize binary uploading binary for
example this case shell from all sex and
visualize an entropy view and suddenly
you see blocks two blocks like this
number three quite clearly just a list
of all symbols and they have the highest
entropy because they are not repeating
as the other two turn out to be
cryptographic signatures of the file
which mako's built-in clearly you can
play with it but more interesting which
were after today how to do discovery how
to find what has changed how to combine
all those things together and the 1 i'll
be talking here today about measuring
relative entropy information game was
using cool backlight library conversions
I'm sorry for pronouncing
let's forget to hell the virgins as we
know it and it's not so true measure
it's a symmetric given you a prior and
your observation you have one outcome
but should you swap them around you'll
get another one and two battle with that
you can actually build symmetric held
businesses and as it was good to
shoulder pretty much on analyzing tax
corporals they give you very similar
results and it can be used
interchangeably so I'm just going for
simpler one that I'm measuring from my
it will be actually prior and my
observation and back and taking the
maximum value however calculating
Hildy's also gives you trouble when
you're dealing with very sparse data
durations clearly some data bits might
be missing and if there is zero it
brings problems so it's not like a
smoothing of lv when actually we
assigned to all terms which are absent
in one of the distributions to tell any
tiny value and then normalize the rest
to sum up to 1 so here it comes demo
application which i'll be talking about
finally and it's how to find surprising
tweets and we when we see tweets we we
are overwhelmed especially when are we
following something big happening and
it's more about can we detect events and
annotate them in short way short of
fashion with those two it's so
unfortunately the data set is a bit
gruesome and i'll be showing in examples
on data i've been collecting over last
year about Ukrainian events that yeah
happening back in my country and yeah so
they weren't that funny first side note
if you want to explore late assassin
just loop with your eyes on this L drop
them into search engine which allows you
to
faceted search I found las Sixers people
are amazing yeah but more about
discovery so this is a whole data set it
gives you data from december to houses
routine up to current point in time
where i still have hopes to find where
love this partition yeah this is lots of
data and i will be always running out of
disk space my node well uh so what I
have here a 75 billion twitch per minute
on average like 500 twits per hour it's
a bit less sure and here is it per day
and you clearly see there is a regular
it is this data set and something
happened if you remember even like new
soon BBC you may recognize some for
example this strike huge strike is the
crash of Malaysian airplane in Ukraine
which was shot and there are others
which ever happening and we worry about
focus on that Prine one which is
experimented a set and here is like for
comparison for you when orientation
Crimea was happening and when president
elections were happening so this data
set is massive in amount of revenge will
happen there following this is a human
reading it it just drives you nuts so if
your data analyst it actually did this
way looking at it gives you some relaxed
approach because you have very birdeye
view so this is experiment data set from
february2014 it has clearly two
different stages when events were
constantly happening but they were kind
of isolated to ukraine and then
something big blast it out and went
really through the world news everybody
wrote about it so because we want to
world music clearly english language
directly dominating especially this last
part is a month so here is the english
only to wait for example which we only
going to analyze just going to filter
out the rest so how does the pipeline
looks in order to look into this just
dream and it looks it we take a time
slot our attention of windows we want to
analyze we will be comparing
against our flyer which consists out of
eight previews time slots and we will be
detecting is it a new event or it's
something to ignore so how we're going
to do it how to calculate kullback
leibler divergence libel or dirty suits
clear but we need somehow to prepare our
data and I will want to show on purpose
for me initially it was simplistic
topple topic modeling do the do the work
we sometimes we all know that we start
super short and can be analyzed easily
with NLP approaches but we already see
how simple mode link bring as a result
so why it works because important events
are widely discussed and we have lots of
tweets events change vocabulary so
actually modeling events with simple
backward approach works and times load
aggregations favors their predominant
events which is negative things to
several events happen I'll see only the
predominant one but since I'm taking
tiny times x lies every time it's sort
of okay so here if we help you talking
in terms of NLP document is time slot
it's not tweet it's a bag of water this
time slot it has a frequency threshold
of any how many tweets each token has to
appear in order to be considered it's
very near term frequency no
normalization by inverse document
frequency and quite a few touches how to
clean through your data because it
requires so clear view and vocabulary
which is kind of sort of power law I'm
not going to claim it and we'll be
focusing only on this tiny and which
actually covers most of the tweets here
is the number of top twist which are top
tokens in this data set which are about
Ukraine retweet Russia Kia president
protest visa
via u.s. crisis everybody's involved in
it so wut kappa rho diversity is the
first thing how many unique talk is with
tokens we have and as we've seen
initially we have two different a part
in it and sure part when world media
kick 10 dominate let bed run out of disk
space actually is also nice to
illustrate how metrics change when you
have a gut in your data so we can do
where simple things we can do vocabulary
hack let's take all catastrophic wars we
describe this gruesome events and see
where they are predominant and those
should correspond to events well sort of
they do but it's still kind of very
regular and they follow the daily cycles
and we cannot really rely on that well
which is detecting it's noon in europe
so we're going to kill the versions and
here i'm showing you the simple approach
that i'm taking his shower and comparing
in the whole dictionary of the whole
months in order to build up
understanding and we have higher values
for K lv4 on sparse data sure because my
my prior which is my distributions or
tokens over the whole months it's huge
and here I'm comparing sparse that's
this only Ukrainian Russian
predominantly tweets be where we have
lots of spies here but there are lots of
events happening it's tiny hours in it I
will dive deeper later smoothing that I
showed you before in the previous slide
I was basically dropping pairs of tokens
which didn't exist in one of the sets
smooshing allows me to compare it and
hole with our dropout and you see
because the smoothing minimum well you
jump sim pretty much on empty if you
compare empty time slot it means it
actually it's not empty all tokens are
equal to this tiny Absalom and here and
I will be doing rolling kaldi because
comparing against the host months it's
not
think I need to compare what has changed
in last time period in my Moodle which
accounts last 24 hours for example in
this case I'm accumulating them it will
be my prior and my tiny hour will be my
observation nice thing that as we
shorten a time slot and for example 8
hour it's a pretty much your day cycle
which covers all bumps of media coming
in we pretty much getting rid of all
daily cycles we are end up only with
spikes it's very happening which four
hours is pretty much the same so on this
way I'm taking eight hours so now we
need to do your van detection again
let's do some super simple I want to
show how information surprise works I
don't want to show how NLP works either
event detection works I'm measuring only
rate changes to surprise of this LD
value I am comparing against the
historic ground rules this is untouched
lots of people also people put their
effort and somebody build a huge time
slot manually rotating every single
event that happened and this is this
immense amount of work and that gives
you something to compare against which
was amazing so here's events were
detected as a rate change and here are
monetizing events was a move surprise in
tokens like which tokens like really
changed here you don't need to read it
but the whole point that we see clearly
here that something happened class has
happened then-president run away then
there was in turn in president and
present basically head of the parliament
and Russian interventions and well us
commenting on that all the events are
coming but they are not descriptive I'm
not going to read tokens it's it's a bit
not human I went to the sender was in
data so let's focus in private events
because I can zoom in on it and they
have better English coverage so here
again this is the same
we have here a bit more advanced but
it's kind of more smooth sir how we're
going to find representative tweet very
simple again we have this time slot and
the upper part of the model is from a
previous pipeline and the first step it
detects testing features but instead of
calculating the cumulative score by
integrating all terms of KL divergence
we leave in them and distribution and
passing into second kubik liberal
diversions and this time we comparing
all twits in my time slot against this
bit which is was the most surprising
between my time slot in my pride and my
prior and by doing so we I'm finding
exactly these tools which are presenting
distant features first of all in first
stage I found tokens which are is unique
to this hour and second stage I found
tweets which are matching exactly this
unique tokens and this way I'm finding
my tooth on which was hidden and then i
can utilize its in this simple demo i'm
not going to show you to scroll through
all events i'm just going to pick up use
few screenshots here and the first i
have to tell you this data set and
purpose hasn't been cleaved from the
bots this data set as lesson thirty two
percent continue sports because this is
was highly sensitive political topic and
russian media was really working hard
net and we haven't like this problem
everywhere in all social middle
challenges channels even up to now I
didn't clean them I didn't clean from
any regular Twitter boats they can be
all detected actually using very similar
entropy mattered because bots behave
very differently and should we capture
both behavior are they repeating
themselves are they acting one after
another and basically trying to discard
their profile with entropic measures are
different I'm not doing this year and so
here we are have we see the first will
be in spam what so because this is the
first tweet actually in our my prior is
empty is actually all tokens beam
equal and so it picks up pretty much the
first tweet which was predominant by its
mass in the first hour the most
surprising for me and doing so that and
all the rest of the tweets which were
selected in this way I don't see not
nobody from spammers I don't see bots
which were forcing the news and
repeating the same tweet which were
hundreds of those in a shower I see
pretty much just media example here
intense clashes rightfully spelling back
petrol bombs to your gas lot of smoke
it's it's went into media so in this
damn i'm selecting one which has like
this high school the second step then
few tweets which help like which follow
it then i was testing a bit different
metric and then i select in the first
tweet with the highest measure which has
me the event in order illustrated sure
not always comes good and for example
here is a comparison it's about related
risk of this integration when russia was
starting to press on Ukraine Crimea and
other media comparing Ukraine to
Venezuela and this is the photo coming
from the seller but actually to its is
same comparison to Ukraine and I looked
into that and turn out this media and
that day in an hour were exactly
comparing events in Ukraine masala and
they were in the same data set I'm sure
when Michelle I was very surprised
called to appear in mine it was actually
quite funny because I later founded a
media when they confuse himself and they
were illustrating Ukrainian weds with
Venezuelan pictures and vice versa so
then horrible things happened there were
like very serious clashes people died
and this is a breaking news which very
went and there was a settlement of
political crisis involving lots of parts
discussion and then president fleeing
old foreign minister turns from capital
from prison what she was doing there
then all talks of us and Russian world
I'm not going to dive into like all
those events are all those play
if you'll believe me they're good and
descriptive and I've been checking again
is that ground truth sure it's not
perfect there are lots of things to
improve but they take out that it's not
that bad right now it's everything back
to normal and those gruesome pictures
you saw its ever seen okay right now
they're well the only building which has
been burned is being diverted to proven
this app we have to benchmark against
media like more directly because Manuel
cannot really work a net we need to
fight with bots because that will help
us to do better topic modeling and in
return it's not disturb frequency to
which have to be treated very
differently and the later bet we need to
split topics because at every point of
time we have lots of events happening we
are dealing with a complex database
which not a single value of a rate it's
a combination of all events happening
but what's amazing with the simple
approaches you can actually achieve
quite a bit and this is was only the
power don't forget your bachelor studies
and before applying very fancy more
techniques however goo they are just
look very simple once thank you well I
rushed through actually it was very
worried they have too many slides yeah
yeah better for yen so we have a
divination questions
no it's I've wrote a tiny yes right I
was sorry Navin asked how I acquired the
data set ah it's not public the only way
official to acquire data settings go to
data scoot of data Swift took nip and
pay quite a bit especially for a long
period of time because they have to
scrape it and I was doing a bit
different hours I wrote a tiny boat
which was still listening to Twitter
streaming API which provides you a
sample tweet when you subscribe a key
words so really clear bias in my sample
I subscribe to a set of keywords which
were representative for those events and
also Ukraine key of the revolution
tweets all my timer all those here basic
in different languages in Ukrainian
Russian and English and this is how I
query the data set despite is being
sample and Twitter does not disclose
exactly the way how they sample it I
found it quite representative it's much
simpler than you think it's very simple
mr. no date as if lost their Twitter
deal so snip and I think another
provider leaders worked they were so
Swift didn't sweat or whatever that's
where they would I they are based here
in reading that's DataSift little
symptoms and they lost their license
with Twitter a few months ago they put
up some slightly acrimonious blog post
saying Twitter we don't like you anymore
you didn't do a deal with us and didn't
erase my lots of other social data they
oh well I'd say I guess I guess that's
why that happened this is the this is
reason for a dataset you get along get
lots of other data from data sift
another question over there
I I like to to know what what you think
it'd be advisable to do topic modeling
like latent models using some kind of
work back or some deep learning
technique what you think will be more
advisable because it's really not clear
how you can model that the topics of
Twitter sure first of all you will end
up with a similar problem that after you
move topic you'll have several different
events happening so you'll have several
different clusters you have to build on
top of this tiny bit which will which
will be splitting your stream of data
into sub streams because well this is
quite a library process and before going
into that you have to figure out whether
it was doing applying work to back
because when I said I didn't didn't do
it because when I first started playing
with this listen to presentation of work
to whack and they was shown I was set by
the owl tree you should not be applying
these two sentences or doing this very
cautiously because it didn't work right
now we know there is it extension to
that which actually works for tweets
work for sentences and nicely captures
sentiments did you do state of the art
but it's all developments I highly
encourage during that but this like
entertaining presentation shows if you
don't need to do it not always hi I'm
out of curiosity what's applications did
you have in mind for this we currently
are continuing to working on this
dataset with my friend who is doing his
postdoc in kings and we are looking
forward to publish the district
description of the
just sat in particular how we are trying
to recognize the differentiate have
forced events on Twitter differ from
organic events and it's very very
interesting problem can we actually
early integrative tell you that this is
a forced opinion which which is a fake
and has been forced by disguise both
network or its organic events which are
reported with people is one of the
things we were looking because we have
data set for that unfortunately it is
manually labeled it's only hundreds of
those fakes and it's kind of hard to map
it to our data set we will get a
statistical description I'm not
confident will to have a proper
classifier for that which will have
enough confidence to do it this is one
of the direction we're looking we're
considering other things but I'm all
open to discussion because we were
sitting on this data and just poking
into it